Bobo you're on the air hey how you doing
there Howard hey Bonnie what's Ronnie's
thinking
I had to start with this [ __ ] I thought
what is we put that to sleep for a while
why but you told us this week was the
week
good
for Christmas break wow you're really
distressed
no I'm not distressed what's going on
pal
all right we're getting married this
fall okay
that's the biggest why are you so
uptight about this because we had a we
had a plan for the you know the
Christmas break show whatever oh I see
whatever yeah like what finally did it
it I got this thing in my head Stephanie
was away
and
I don't know I got my bug up my ass to
go talk to somebody about it a bug in a
dildo
and uh another thing up his ass
I wanted to surprise her when she came
back that I had went and talked to these
people about doing this with like a
wedding hall people or some place where
you want to have a wedding some some
dude that I know and like what did you
do uh she [ __ ] wants to [ __ ] get
married no I just said that I didn't
want a big deal thing but then again
she's never had it so you know I guess
you know
are you excited about it at all Ron look
I would be thrilled to go like do it at
like city hall or whatever
right and then just have the big party
afterwards with everybody okay getting
up in front of everybody at my [ __ ]
age and doing this kind of [ __ ] okay a
thousand the whole [ __ ] thing I get
it and you know who do you think is
going to be the first person to yell out
something stupid Sal or who do you think
is going to be the person
[Music]
right yeah [ __ ] with my wedding cake I
know we will Robin Ronnie got engaged in
March of 2016. yeah he's been he has
somehow avoided this nightmare of him
having to get up in front of everyone
and pronounce his love Ronnie's a hard
ass he you know he he has a hard time
even saying he's in love with her you
know what I mean so this is like
lovey-dovey romantic Ronnie's got he is
this is way out of this man's comfort
zone Blitz Sal and uh Pearlman come on
here for a second I want to have a talk
with you guys
let's talk for real sound okay yeah I've
seen you do the dumbest [ __ ] at weddings
we were at the bar and you said uh Sal
do something stupid and I said I did I
came here
but I know how do you know the book me
and you went over to the book where you
sign off and congratulate the bride and
groom and I was drawing pictures of Gary
and his teeth and
how many minutes do you think it could
last watching Ronnie walking down the
aisle in a traditional wedding before
you something stupid like you'll keep
your mouth shut how long how long
I'd say 30 seconds
you know how people throw rice at the
wedding yeah I'm going to throw pills of
stool softener
when Ronnie walks down the aisle I'm
going to follow him with a wheelchair in
case he falls
that's a good one Mike
what what thoughts are you having are
you excited it's so hard to take him
seriously like he's just so he should
everything about him is such a like a
joke so seeing him in any type of
serious matter like walking down an
aisle getting married at 70 plus years
old it's going to be funny but then
again this is always the caveat yeah I
don't want to piss him off I always feel
like I'm pissing him off with this [ __ ]
like I don't want to be in his head
while he's getting married you know what
I mean yeah they were all in gonna be in
my head already
but what are you thinking about Ronnie
in the big announcement I'm really happy
for him and them and and I think it's
amazing and I think I may grow up Ronnie
mustache I think it's a similar oh
that's fine and dress like exactly like
and maybe tell people I'm his his
illegitimate son from a past marriage
I'll tell that to Kurt Bush or something
that could be something fun to do who's
gonna marry you are you serious you got
an Elvis yeah oh is that for real yes
oh why are you doing that does she want
that ask her originally we were gonna do
it at the original Elvis Chapel uh
but it only holds like 30 people and
what Stephanie's into Elvis Elvis was
dead before Stephanie was born what are
you doing this is what you listen this
is what she wants how long does it take
Ronnie to get completely [ __ ] wasted
and start yelling 69 and wives shits and
all that and [ __ ] into the microphone
you think he would do that at his own
wedding
100 and it's going to be drunken unleash
Ronnie
marry me Elvis I'm so [ __ ] drunk I
say tree Elvises we got to do that move
where we lift Ronnie up in his chair am
I hearing we am I here yeah wait oh yeah
I'm not missing this are you [ __ ]
crazy hey you guys hear that yeah I'm
going to this
I'm shocked as you let me ask you this
you inviting Fred Fred's definitely on
the list Fred I got a request I'm
begging you as you know a guy I've
worked with 40 years or something yes
you got to bring the uh Ronnie puppet
away I actually I would be willing to
stand next
you know I'll put a [ __ ] black thing
over me and it'll just be it'll be and
it'll be the Ronnie puppet
what would the Ronnie puppet's attitude
be like what would he be doing
hey
get ready to dance the horror with your
Horrors yeah
[Laughter]
warm up the wedding
yeah and you know what would be funny if
you jump in because Ronnie's not gonna
have good vows you got to jump in with
the vows roses are red Violet's of blue
rub those [ __ ] lips
[Applause]
Stephanie's here yeah she's awake let me
uh say something first of all
congratulations to getting the the
they're all excited for you you finally
did it you're gonna have the big wedding
and it's great like but what's going to
be really weird is to get Ronnie to be
romantic and like you know yes you know
be present for it and be loving I think
we'll finally get to see the side of
Ronnie that I always get to see you're
envisioning even a first dance with
Ronnie right yes yeah I am would you
encourage Ronnie to get dance lessons I
think that would be great
um lifts and stuff yeah they do well
congratulations I think you got yourself
a great catch there you know how I love
Ronnie I can't we want you to have the
wedding of your dreams oh yeah Sal and
blit they'll see to it don't worry the
plane flight is going to be like a
Rider's meeting for all the [ __ ] we're
gonna do at Ronnie's wedding well I'm
going to tell you something and I'm
saying this I'm saying this to my staff
we have to begin planning all the comedy
bits we're going to be doing there right
now
I'm calling off Christmas break and
everybody's going to be writing full
time
foreign